wenn es außerirdisches leben gibt dann
sind die chancen dort mit am höchsten
auf dem jupitermond europa doch kann
leben hier tatsächlich existieren die
nasa will genau das mit hilfe der europa
clipper mission klären und hat jetzt
tesla und spacex chef elon musk mit ins
boot geholt mit hilfe seiner ferien
heavy trägerrakete soll es schon in drei
jahren
2024 zum jupitermond europa gsm lucia
regens dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts
herzlich willkommen wie schon in drei
jahren
2024 soll die mission zum jupitermond
europa starten eigentlich war eine sms
raketen der nasa für den start
vorgesehen doch aus diesem
ursprünglichen plan wird wohl nichts
kostensteigerungen und verzögerungen
hatten deren entwicklung in der
vergangenen zeit geprägt jetzt hat die
nasa die konsequenzen gezogen und tesla
gründer und spacex chef elon musk mit
ins boot geholt denn die europa kipper
mission soll stattfinden und zwar schon
bald jetzt allerdings mit einer fetten
heavy schwerlast rakete die bereits
mehrere erfolgreiche missionen hinter
sich hatten wie genau wird die mission
ablaufen und wie groß sind die chancen
dass wir auf dem jupitermond europa
tatsächlich außerirdisches leben
dingfest machen können die spannenden
antworten auf all diese fragen gibt
jetzt bei diesem science and future auf
den ersten blick wirkt der jupitermond
lebensfeindlich und vor allem kalt doch
der erste eindruck täuscht denn unter
seiner eisigen kruste verbirgt sich ein
gigantischer ozean aus flüssigem wasser
verschiedene forschungsteams hatten in
der vergangenheit intensiv untersucht ob
neben dem flüssigen wasser noch weitere
zutaten vorhanden sind die für die
existenz von leben notwendig sind und
die ergebnisse sind spannend denn es
sind gleich drei dinge die der
jupitermond europa bietet und genau die
machen ihn für astronomen astronomen
weltweit so spannend schutz vor
strahlung aus dem all wärmeenergie und
flüssiges wasser all das sind mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit genau die drei
wesentlichen voraussetzungen die für die
existenz von leben wichtig sind all das
braucht es also um biologische systeme
hervorzubringen die oberfläche von
europa ist sehr hell und auch sehr jung
was darauf schliessen dass der mond
geologisch aktiv ist unter seine
eiskruste befindet sich wohl ein ozean
aus flüssigem wasser die wissenschafts
community geht davon aus dass dieser
salzig ist und von strömungen durchzogen
chemische reaktionen könnten dafür
sorgen dass auch nährstoffe und
sauerstoff in diesem so platzieren ozean
vorhanden sind an den polen des
jupitermond europa gibt es wasserdampf
von denen die dafür sorgen dass ein
austausch mit der oberfläche stattfinden
kann sein planet jupiter der größte
planet des sonnensystems knete den mond
so richtig durch reibung entsteht durch
die gezeitenkräfte und so wird das fest
der innere des jupiter mond es richtig
aufgeheizt die eisdecke ist zwischen 10
und 20 kilometer dick und bildet somit
einen guten strahlenschutz für den ozean
der darunter liegt die wärmeenergie als
eine wichtige voraussetzung von leben
stammt aus den enormen gezeigten
bewegungen und dem radioaktiven zerfall
der elemente im festen kern des mondes
was dazu kommt der ozean hat ebenfalls
kontakt zum kern chemische reaktionen
entstehen wenn dort material ausgelöst
wird auch das kann dann energie liefern
erst vor kurzer zeit hatte sich ein
tschechisches forschungsteam diesen
heitz effekt genauer angeschaut in einer
aktuellen studie hatten die forscher aus
prag untersucht ob sogar am grund des
ozeans hydrothermale strothe ja
vielleicht sogar vulkane existieren
könnten mit der hilfe eines
geophysikalischen modells konnten die
fachleute rekonstruieren wie stark sich
europa seit seiner entstehung abgekühlt
hat wie viel wärmeenergie die
gezeitenkräfte liefern und wie stark
dadurch der silikat mantel des jupiter
mondes auf schmilzt das ergebnis ist
eindeutig und rückt europa noch mehr in
den fokus der zahlreichen forschen den
weltweit die auf der suche nach
außerirdischem leben sehen denn laut der
analyse des forschungsteams könnte das
innere des mondes heiß genug sein um
unterseeische vulkanausbrüche auszulösen
die eruptionen am grund des sozialen
ozeans könnten sogar so stark gewesen
sein wie die einiger super vulkane auf
unsere auch heute noch könnten sogar
noch hydrothermale schlote und aktive
untersee vulkane vorhanden sein und das
macht europa ganz besonders das
forschungsteam aus prag schreibt dazu
europa ist einer der seltenen
himmelskörper die ihre vulkanische
aktivität über milliarden jahre hinweg
gehalten haben könnten er könnte zu dem
neben der erde der einzige himmelskörper
im sonnensystem sein der sowohl große
wasservorkommen als auch eine langlebige
energiequelle besitzt die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vermuten die lava aus dritte und
hydrothermalen schloten am ehesten in
der pole des mondes die erklärung dafür
hängt mit den gezeigten kräften zusammen
da diese die meiste hitze im inneren von
europa erzeugen auch die nasa hatte
stellung zu dieser erkenntnis genommen
kein wunder denn solche unterseeische
vulkane und heiße quellen gelten als
mögliche orte der entstehung von leben
beispielsweise auch auf der erde der
nasa mit dabei darüber parlando hatte
die studie aus prag so kommentiert die
aussicht auf einen heißen gesteins kern
und vokaler auf den meeresgrund von
europa erhöhen die chance dass es dort
eine lebensfreundliche umgebung gibt ein
grund mehr also der für eine zeitnahe
mission zum jupitermond europa spricht
die nasa will die europa kicker mission
im oktober 2004 und 20 staaten beim
namen vorbeiflügen soll gezielt nach
hinweisen auf die lebens freundlichkeit
gesucht werden und außerdem auch die
zusammensetzung des sub platzieren
ozeans analysiert werden 40 bis 50 mal
soll der jupitermond dabei aus nächster
nähe passiert werden die analysen
könnten dann unter anderem offenbaren ob
sich tatsächlich vulkan unter dem eis
des jupiter mondes verbergen dafür
eingesetzt werden sollen kameras und
spektrometer um hochauflösende bilder
der oberfläche zu machen so will man an
überaus detaillierte informationen über
europa kommen auch die zusammensetzung
der oberfläche des jupiter monde soll
bestimmt werden genauso wie die dicke
der eisigen schale des bundes wie ist
der salzgehalt des ozeans und welche
anzeichen neuer oder anhaltender
geologische aktivitäten gibt es fragen
über fragen doch wer genau führt den
start dieser mission aus hier ist die
nasa nun endlich einen entscheidenden
schritt weiter die entscheidung ist
final getroffen vor einigen tagen ende
juli 2000 20 hatte die us
raumfahrtbehörde bekannt gegeben dass
dieser auftrag an elem us-raumfahrt
unternehmen spacex geht die falcon heavy
rakete soll also in drei jahren abheben
ihre schubkraft entspricht der von 18
jumbo jets die kosten für den staat rund
178 millionen us dollar doch das ist
immer noch deutlich günstiger als wenn
die nasa ihre eigene rakete space launch
system sls nutzen würde nach
medienberichten kann die nasa durch die
auftragsvergabe an spacex insgesamt zwei
milliarden dollar einsparen doch einen
wermutstropfen gibt es denn der flug zum
jupiter mond wird somit länger dauern
insgesamt fünfeinhalb jahre wird die
sonde brauchen bis sie dann im april
2030 europa erreichen wird die flugdauer
war auch ein argument warum die nasa so
lange auf die eigene sls rakete gesetzt
hatte damit wäre der flug nämlich in
rund drei oder vier jahren zu schaffen
gewesen es war ein harter politischer
diskurs denn der us kongress hatte lange
darauf gedrängt die sls rakete
einzusetzen doch wäre diese zum
starttermin 2024 überhaupt bereit
gewesen das ist viel zu unsicher und im
schlimmsten fall hätte man die mission
dann nach hinten schieben müssen nun
soll sich der flugzeugbauer boeing der
für die triebwerke der sls rakete
zuständig ist voll und ganz auf die
aktives mission konzentrieren die
bereits im jahr 2024 astronautinnen und
astronauten auf den mond bringen will
wobei dieses datum nicht zu schaffen ist
wir haben hier bei gibsons als im
vorjahr exklusiv als erste darüber
berichtet und zwei projekte dieser
größenordnung sind den nasa offiziellen
dann offensichtlich doch noch eine
nummer zu groß die entscheidung wem us
firma spacex fiel relativ leicht denn
die fetten henne ist bereits drei mal
geflogen und für die europa kipper
mission waren drei erfolgreiche start
sowie mindestens zwei erfolgreiche
starts hintereinander eine der
voraussetzung im übrigen ist das nicht
die einzige jupiter mission die in
planung ist im sommer des kommenden
jahres 2022 soll eine sonde der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa staaten
jupiter simons explorer im visier die
gallische monde des jupiters vor allem
gani med callisto aber eben auch europa
auch hier steht die eine forschungsfrage
an erster stelle ermöglichen diese monde
die existenz von leben und sind sie
möglicherweise sogar vergeben gewesen
und im jahr 2002 30 wird die esa sonde
in die umlaufbahn von gani med eintreten
und sich auf bis zu 200 kilometer nähern
auch gar nicht beherbergt wurde unter
seiner eisigen oberfläche einen ozean
aus flüssigem wasser möglicherweise
könnte in diesem monat mehr sogar mehr
wasser enthalten sein als alle ozeane
der erde zusammen doch nicht nur dass
ein deutsches forschungsteam hat erst in
diesen tagen eine aktuelle studie dazu
veröffentlicht demnach ist es den
astronomen astronom sogar gelungen auch
wasserdampf um den eysmondt nachzuweisen
und auch hier sieht es nach leben
ausleben auf saturnmond enceladus der
beweis anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren das geht hier oder mit dem
abo button unter jedem video das ist
kostenlos und macht schlauch ist dann
dran